bounty hunting is a complicated process
oh dear Korea d23 is officially in the
can and Disney had a little something
more like a lot of something for
everyone especially Star Wars man here's
everything we learned at d23 right now
on the catch up with the streaming
service Disney Plus launching in just a
few short months on November 12 there
were plenty of announcements and updates
including the first trailer for Jon
Favreau Star Wars series the Mandalorian
the trailer features the familiar visual
figures frozen in carbonite and an
aesthetic that would make any fan
excited including the show star Pedro
Pascal who we actually talked to you on
the d23 red carpet it's so weird to be
in something that you would want to see
so badly and let's just say the force
was strong this weekend friends because
it was also confirmed by Lucasfilm
president Kathleen Kennedy and Ewan
McGregor himself that an obi-wan Kenobi
series is officially coming to Disney
Plus and that it will be set in a time
that coincides with the events of so low
a Star Wars story according to a
timeline shown during P 23 and are you
sitting down for this one another Star
Wars series which hasn't been named yet
will feature roblins diego luna and alan
tudyk reprising their roles as cassie
and ander and k2s so did you know that
wasn't me when it comes to Marvel
projects on Disney plus we learned that
Emily VanCamp will return as Sharon
Carter in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series which as Sebastian Stan
showed us features the rather impressive
anthony mackie stepping in as the new
Captain America have you seen my we're
at 8.0 today alright it was awesome
revealed that kat dennings and randall
park will reprise their MCU roles in
Wanda vision with Kathryn Hahn announced
as the nosy neighbor in the upcoming
show which is said to have a 50 square
writer Jack Schaeffer said it will be
half sitcom half epic MCU adventure and
it sounds like a whole lot of fun
on top of that three more Marvel series
were announced MS marvel moon a and
she-hulk in other words it's time to
redownload that food delivery app
because you're not leaving your couch
like ever but even with all the Star
Wars and Marvel Heights the real stars
at the Disney Plus rollout were the
adorable dogs from the new live-action
movie Lady and the [ __ ] which had its
first trailer drop on Friday no
confirmation on if they shared a plate
of spaghetti though I'm kidding and yep
I'm still going now we can all watch
Mike Wazowski because an animated series
called monsters at work is also in the
works and on top of all of that fan
favorite for key from Toy Story 4 we'll
be getting his own short film series
called porky asks a question fans also
got the first trailer for Noel with Anna
Kendrick and Bill Hader and for good
measure we got a first look at the world
according to Jeff Goldblum so you're
welcome be forewarned I'm in the show a
lot on the Disney movie side of things
in d23 Star Wars and Marvel once again
dominated the headlines a new poster for
the rise of Skywalker was released along
with footage that revealed Rey wearing a
black robe and using a double-sided red
lightsaber something that had both fans
and the cast talking and jaws dropping
and Jojo spent all that Bob Ross like
you read the script oh that's crazy
that's the first time I've seen it like
that and Keri Russell revealed that her
character and the rise of Skywalker is
named is ory bliss and described her as
a cool and shady criminal who has a
history with Poe Dameron and I see the
note like dating history
I need more specifics here when it comes
to Marvel movies along with Angelina
Jolie and the rest of the advocate irnos
cast making an appearance Kevin Feige
announced a game of Thrones star Kit
Harington will play Dayne Whitman in the
film slated for next November Whitman is
known as Black Knight in Marvel Comics
so insert your own nights watch to joke
here
there was also an official poster
release for the upcoming Black Widow
movie with our first look at David
Harbor as bred Guardian so used to
seeing him in a Hawaiian shirt now and
director Ryan Coogler announced that
black panther - we'll have a release day
of May 6 2022 more like Wakanda is
taking forever just tell Alexa to set a
reminder
and as many expected both Tom Holland
and Feige address the recent news that
spider-man is leaving the MC Holland
said I'm going to continue playing
spider-man and having the time of my
life it's going to be so fun however we
choose to do it with Feige adding we
knew there was a finite amount of time
that we'd be able to do this and we
pulled the story we wanted to tell and
I'll always be thankful for that what
just happened in other Disney movie news
Swain Johnson made an epic entrance to
d23 by arriving on his own riverboat
then Emily Blunt showed up in a vintage
car and together they gave us a first
look at Jungle Cruise which they promise
is quote the adventure of a lifetime but
if it's not is anyone really gonna try
and hold a rock to it we also finally
got to see Emma Stone as Cruella De Vil
in Cruella and if she doesn't scare you
no evil thing will Emma said karela will
take place in London during the punk
rock era of the 70s so I feel like that
soundtracks gonna be late
moving on a Pixar well they had a pretty
big presence at d23 - with Seoul which
is coming next June and starring the
voices of Jamie Foxx and Tina Fey Plus
onward which will read a Avengers Tom
Holland and Chris Pratt only this time
is animated elf brothers elsewhere in
the world of Disney Animation we learned
that aquafina will play seishu the
dragon in Disney's upcoming animated
film Riya and the Last Dragon and
perhaps the most important thing of all
that happened at d23 the cast of frozen
clothes things out by serenading the
crowd with one of two brand new songs
revealed from frozen - plus fans got a
first look at characters voice by new
additions like Sterling Kay brown and
Evan Rachel Wood I know you want to
scream with excitement so go ahead just
let it go
now that Disney has given us many
reasons to live I want to kick it over
to you now what are you most excited for
Star Wars stuff Marvel stuff
frozen anybody also will you be getting
Disney Plus and should dogs be allowed
to eat spaghetti really hard-hitting
questions here let us know all your
thoughts in the comment section and if
you liked this episode and you want to
see more subscribe and click that Bell
icon so you can check out future
episodes as always I'm now spreads and
I'll see you guys
[Music]